ميدانيا مرت عشره اشهر على اندلاع معركه
بخموت ولا تزال هذه المدينه تترنح بين
موسكو وكياف القوات الروسيه المدعومه
بمقاتلي باجنر لم تنجح رغم المحاولات
العديده في بسط السيطره الكامله على
المدينه فماذا لو كانت معركه بخموت مجرد
فخ اوكرانيا لاستنزاف القوات الروسيه
صحيفه وول ستريت جورنا نشرت تقريرا يشير
الى ان كاف تعمدت اطاله المعارك في باخمت
وذلك بهدف انهاك القوات الروسيه كما نقلت
الصحيفه تصريحا للمتحدث باسم القوات
الاوكرانيه
يشير فيه الى التعمد اوكرانيا استدراج
القوات الروسيه الى ما وصفه بفخ بخموت
مضيفا ان هذه الخطه نجحت في اضعاف العدو
على حد قوله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات